living in a country of fear and terror
wrapped senegalese artist deep down
geese the police are supposed to protect
us today they're the one killing us you
can't stop us from protesting because
you sold your country to france he says
accusing president
of protecting french corporations
instead of the people
it's up to us young people to change
things we can't wait for leaders to do
things for us
we have to wake up and fight for the
future of our country
free senegal is a rap song turned into
an anthem for many young people here
like unemployed carpenter and or who
after the burning and looting of a
french supermarket
picked through the remains for food
lured by the promise of work endure
moved to the capital after sal's
re-election two years ago
sal started major infrastructure
projects
but then once booming economy is now
stalling since the current virus
pandemic
i voted for i thought he would move us
forward but he's moving us backwards
some say it's turning into a
dictatorship we need to protect our
democracy
it belongs to the people not to the
politicians
critics of the government accuse the
president of using the court to
eliminate opponents protests broke out
after opposition leader usman sanko was
arrested
accused of rape in february he has since
been released but several politicians
civil society actors and trade unionists
have been arrested local media estimates
600 people were detained
some are now awaiting trial while the
protests have stopped for now the anger
has not subsided for rights groups and
the opposition those detained inside
this courtroom
are political prisoners that need to be
freed immediately for the court
and the government they're criminals
that are involved in public disturbance
and the looting of private property
and door says he is not a looter but
just a man trying to get by
in a country where many of the young are
fed up
with waiting for the change they were
promised
nicholas hawk al jazeera dakar